- Well, bladesmiths, your
weapons
will now be put through
a series of three tests.
There will be a strength
test, a sharpness test,
and up first, the kill test.
Doug.
Bladesmiths, this
is the kill test.
To see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do,
I will take your
weapon and deliver
some slashes and thrusts
on this pig carcass.
Ethan, you're up first.
Are you ready?
I am so ready.
I have never made a sword
anywhere near this large
before.
I came in to it with
a mindset of victory,
so we'll see how this goes.
Bladesmiths, please
welcome back Anthony Palmer.
Anthony is one of the chief
instructor of Marcaida Kail,
and today he will
have the pleasure
of wielding your weapons.
I was actually hoping
for Dave Baker on a horse,
but this is a good secondary.
[music playing]
All right.
How'd it feel?
First up, there were
no issues whatsoever
with your edge over here.
It is sharp.
It lacerates and cuts clean.
Look at that-- razor
cuts right there.
On the thrust, you
have an angle here
that allowed for a deep
thrust, pulling out
and slashing on the way out.
Overall, your weapon will kill.
All right, Liam.
Your turn.
You ready?
- Oh, yeah.
Let's do it.
After a catastrophic fire, loss
of equipment, critical tools,
still made another blade with
10 hours left on the clock.
I'm happy with the fact
that I got the sword
done for the challenge.
But so many things
could go wrong.
I don't even know if I was able
to get a good, solid temper
on this blade.
I just hope that this
wasn't for nothing.
[music playing]
Well, Liam, let me say
this-- first up, your presence
here is a victory.
All the things that
you went through,
and you still turn
in a blade that's
beautiful in craftsmanship,
that is very sharp.
But your blade did break.
And you can see right
here in the cross section,
there's a discoloration
down here.
So something happened in
your heat treating process,
and it may have micro-fractures.
It is what it is.
Liam, there was a
flaw in your blade
that led to a catastrophic
blade failure,
and we can no longer
continue with testing.
For that reason, I have to ask
you to please leave the forge.
Thank you, gentlemen.
I'm upset.
The fire really broke down
what I was able to turn in.
But I didn't give up.
It was something that I was
raised with, with my dad.
It really sunk in with me
when I was in the military.
Sometimes the best you can
do isn't going to be enough,
but that doesn't mean
you shouldn't still try.